hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, so the next topic we have is how we are gonna be working together.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And the major points we wanted to cover was your availability, modes of communication, onboarding, and the documentation resources that we should have.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, for availability, I think this lot kind of works in the enterprise.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Because that's when the RFP is looking really bad. So, Thursdays around this time, it needs to respond.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And very quickly, I think we're all available on GM still, so if you ever have to ask something about it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And, promotes a community initiative on the users, depending on those of them.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: What we do is we probably provision around, like, paragraphs for RP, so that you all have part of our teams, and we can extend it for any time.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Other than that, for the onboarding process, it's pretty open, which is, we, give you access to whatever you need for the initial part of the application or, various resources, and how the data looks type for various parts of the project.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And, you can test it to deliver on the windows.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So probably we'll ask you guys to, invest in your annual times by graph, or we'll give you feedback, if that's,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We don't do that, right? So we just ask you many items that we already have those, and then you just onboard you out to our system so that you have access to, like, the other things.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And as we grow… as we go about the project, we give you more and more access. Because it's not a long process, at least with us, so as long as you ping me, Jake or David, you will get your access of that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And also, please include the mentor who's access on Teams. Yeah, 100%.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, you should. Yeah. We'd like to know what you guys are talking about. I don't want the team to promise the moon.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I also wanted to ask about the documentation, with that, like, which, Apprentice use,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So to have access to the previous team's documentation really depends. It might be useful for them to understand that. You can share that across, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Perfect.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I'm going on.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: final onboarding docs so we can be set with those.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But you've changed things since then? Yeah. Yeah, we've not so much changed so much and added. We've added a lot of things, but yeah, we should make sure that's…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, that'd be okay for me, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Next to the project purpose and background.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: From your guys' point of view, the motivation, benefits, stakeholder of the feature you're gonna try to build.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Hey, guys.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, with the motivation of it, it's mainly to, I think.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: get the process of getting the initial product data in a reliable manner onto the system. That's, I think, is the only one we can play.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Because I think right now, the only way we can probably do that better is by just getting more data and probably having more people look at the data and understand it, which is not the way to go about it, because that's not scalable anymore, like, just moving product.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I want to add that too, yeah, just… there's a lot… it's a very human process right now to, like, one vendor sends something one format, another vendor sends something another format. Teams of people have to go through and interpret it, and then try and
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: RAM, whatever that is, into the existing structure or, like, attributes or ways of looking.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And, just that process. We'd like to make that a lot more hands-off, where they can just upload something, it'll get it in there, and then they can do future modification. Maybe it's not right or wrong, but just getting it in there in the first place takes so much time right now.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then… and then once thin, making it as robust as possible. So, filling out all of the attributes that a particular product might have, be that by scraping the PDFs, or scraping a vendor website, or whatever we need to do to try to get those back from people without them knowing an entrance.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Is kind of step two, in my sense, and then step three is… is…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I forget what you called it. It's like, there's, like, a man-in-the-middle kind of concept for female blue. Yeah, that's it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: There's a freedom in the loop concept where, yeah, we'll do as much as we can, and we'll probably need some approvals on that and whatnot, but then also, like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: what needs updated? What, can we, like, score products so that we see, like, how big each product is, that we can pull up a download of products that is, like, all of these are, like, you know, 20% down there. I mean, we're, like…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: How can we get to that next step of at least telling the human what they need to do more work on? They're not telling the AI what it needs to be able to work on.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I'm curious, what is the frequency of new vendors coming on board and you have to ingest those data? I imagine it's very modest for you.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, we're open to increase this more and more with the new product that we're launching. It is aimed at the small and medium-sized business market. So, most of our clients right now are, like, enterprise clients, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For them, we're always onboarding more vendors, but it's not like 100 vendors haven't done yet. Hopefully, in the future, it will be moved.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But a lot of that's gonna be overlap, so that vendor A sells, like, Apple.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And vendor B also sells Apple, but we need to make a good catalog of, like, Apple devices, and then be able to link them up to each vendor, and add on the original vendor attributes from there. Part of that is just already built when they're being built, and are doing stuff.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, make sure that I have all the attributes that it needs with as little interconnection as possible.
Dennis Grinberg: And Bill, do you have any…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh, go ahead.
Dennis Grinberg: I was gonna say, do you have any… data around…
Dennis Grinberg: I guess two things. One is how accurate humans are at this endeavor.
Dennis Grinberg: And the second is…
Dennis Grinberg: If you think about the, you know, the total sort of workflow, I don't know what your workflow is, but I can imagine, you know, looking at the data, entering it, someone else verifying it, like, where the, you know, analysis of how much time is spent on those different
Dennis Grinberg: Activities within that work, workflow.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: No, I was just gonna say, we are currently actually fully launching gyms to production now, so all the workflows that we've done are on the legacy L1 systems. So I don't have good methods to start with them on how long it takes.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We… now that VIMS is launching, we can start recording that as the current state, so that we can see how much better we are at the end of the year.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then, what was the first part of that question, too?
Dennis Grinberg: What… how accurate are humans at this activity?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, I guess we could use those metrics,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh, no, I don't know if we have how accurate, like, we could easily show… Yeah, like, what a good end, goal of it is based on, like, the PDF we took at the beginning, but for accuracy, that's a good question. So what I was going to say was, we could surely connect that information and send it to… send it across to you.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We just haven't acted at the beginning of the night. I don't know if.
Dennis Grinberg: team's gonna need it, but just… these are just, like, things that, hey, I'm interested, I'm curious.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You'd like some metrics to see what the overall process on which it's improved. So I guess the one question would be, you ingest the data, you've got it there. Are there, future reports to say the data's inaccurate? Do you have information like that, or…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, how do you discover that? It's usually word of mouth, or yeah, the people using our site, or the catalog team will notice something, and then they'll go in and change that, or our salespeople will, in talking to customers, realize something's wrong, or not acting, or they're missing. In the new product, we'll probably have a crowdsourcing element doing that, where people
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's for having this information on the record.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But you have no centralized loading, according to that model. The bigger problem now is probably, as we add…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: new suppliers for our existing clients. It's pretty easy to get a part and a price in there, to actually know all the attributes.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We're not doing it a lot of the time, because it's just too much effort, for us to spend on all of the new product lines that are being added.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But for the end user, of course, it would be very helpful to have the gas release. So, for the sake of getting it up and running, and it works, and they can technically buy it, not having them is fine, and that's what we do, but we're looking at how can we get that better user experience with marketing.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Just some background and context, too, into, like, the… just the attributes in general. We… we have a lot of attributes. The catalog team, really, the majority of their time is looking at more attributes and coming up with… coming up with different ways to classify things. So, we're especially in the building controls industry.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Like, there's not one in this room, but, like, a valve for a pipe, like, in the bathroom or something like that. Like, they want to know what material it is, what the pressure rating is, the heat resistance rating, like, we… it's really driven, and that is we…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Because when they're going to look up parts, they don't really care about the brand, they just want to be able to filter by, I need this rating, I need these to handle this pressure, needs to handle this temperature range, automatic off, like, normally closed, like, it's really around the attributes, as opposed to where we've been making the iPhone, but that's…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: that's a little more, like, you know you want an iPhone when you go. This was more like, you don't care what brand it is, you know you need 16 gigs on your phone, or you need, like, 5G. Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So the thinking is, for each kind of product category, a human is already doing this, and probably because she'll be making, like, this category of products needs this set of activities.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So then, when you're trying to ingest the product, first we have to try to figure out what category is. This buyer can probably give us something first on that, meaning they match product for ours.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then the second step is, okay, now I know what category it is, it needs all these attributes, I like this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So does the vendor sometimes supply spec sheets? Yes, yes. Do you link parts to spec sheets or not? Yep, yeah, we have a lot of parts linked to spec sheets today. But again, the challenge with new parts, like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Ideally, the vendor is giving us a link to a spec sheet when they're giving us the product, and that can be helpful to you guys. We've been trying to pull that spec sheet into our own control and work off of it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's not always going to be that easy, but in the best case scenario, they do. Sometimes we don't, though, and the catalog team literally goes out to their websites, their lipsticks, they can go online and tries to infer, and then put that in.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think you also mentioned in the presentation before that, some vendors, give you guys some catalogs, like, physical catalogs, or, like, so the catalog team has to, like, manually enter all the data from that?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And as a part of this, we'll want to automate that as well, right? Like, a way to…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, so it's not… it used to be that we'd get, like, they would try to, like, enter in as much as we could. We're not dealing with that anymore, but they still might get a big gap, right? Like, but more often than not, the vendor is able to give us something digitally, some sort of self-spread key or whatever.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So that's the bulk of what we're trying to focus on. Good question, how structured or unstructured the data is? Yeah, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: If thereof.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: kind of, like, an ideal layout of form that you, kind of have in mind for, like, each part, like, accept those terms should ideally have, like, use both listed for each.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, there's definitely, like, a basic schema below where, like, it needs a product number, which is, like,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: what you refer to it as the name of the product, and then we have supplier product number. Sometimes, like, suppliers have their own, way that they, like, label a product versus what they sell to the public. Couple more fields, like description, list, cost,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But after that, the rest is all gets into attributes and just kind of more, like, things associated with it. Yeah, and that's what I'm saying, a human can say, like, what category is tablets, right? So, like, what's the screen size of the tablet? Is it, like, pen enabled? What, what, like, standard of pen devices does this tablet use?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: What color is it, of course, like, humans, obviously brand this kind of separate thing, but we keep going on and on. We can have humans to find, like, tablets and make those funny things.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then, it's kind of you guys' job to figure out how they get those funny things from the, like, whatever we're giving from the vendors, and work them into, like, what we want them to do. Yeah. We do have, like, a chat meeting and an annual meeting, where we have
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: attributes map the latest products within the field. So that's… so that… Yeah, so, like, with the tablets, Joe just listed some, like, we would have the category of tablets, and then we would have attributes assigned to that. So all tablets should have the attribute of screen size. All tablets should have the attribute of pen enabled.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then as we upload a new product into the tablet category, we automatically know, okay, it needs a value for string size, it needs a value for Venity, like, so we have…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the value that the product has, is downstream of us, like, before that, matching an attribute to a category, and then everything in the category has to have value to spend on the attribute.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And that gets back to what Joe was saying earlier, like, the third part, which is saying this product is 20% ready. We would have a way to kind of do that based on, like, you've only entered 2 of the 10 attributes associated with this
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Products category, product, we need to know.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the screen status. You can enter a screen status, that could be a way to determine what information is missing. We're not always doing this yet. We can also rank, right, these are the top four attributes that are absolutely needed to go into this product, and then the rest of them advanced away the extra… it would be nice to have them, but…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Ideally, we have these four groups.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Is there… I know before we talked about the most sensitive thing from the vendor when it's pricing. Is there any correction of information about a product that makes it more sensitive or not, or are you advancing in any state?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's really just the pricing. One or two brands that are a little picky with, like, who can see their products, so, we just… But, yeah, it's just a matter of, like, who can actually sell their products, but that's not something that we can still go on their website to buy and see most of their products publicly.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So the only thing we're really concerned about doing Friday was probably
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: from the looks of it, that I think we'll have to have discussions with the catalog team, just to understand how exactly they, like, search all the information, so we can do the same thing, just in an automated fashion. So, like, we'll have
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: access to them, like you said, you can miss them on Teams, or love to… you can come over to ePass as well for meeting them in person.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We could catalog team with the e-ports catalog team.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we can probably, like… you would be able to message, so, like, the catalog work that we have at eBARTS. Our parent company, Ops Control Trolls, has a much larger, catalog team.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: No, with them, that would probably be, yeah, something in person would be ideal, but… Yeah, if you can come back, that'll be easier for them as well. But with the eParts catalog person, yeah, you could feel free to reach out to them on Teams. Apparently, it helps those most of the catalog work, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We do some… like I said, we don't worry about the attributes as much.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Just because there's, like, one or two people in our movement does catalog at all, and they also do other things. It's still only, like, four people, but they're all actually dedicated to cataloging. We'll get a ton of…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And they are… Alps is an e-commerce, like, distributor in their building control space, so they are highly incentivized to make… break down our data wigs so that they're helping their customers buy the right thing because they bought them that instead of someone else.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Alright.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Most of our customers, it's the tools where,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the engineer needs to, you know, they're, like, kind of locked in using our platform for the corporate or whatever. So it's, like, okay to not have the best catalog data. We don't want the better. Alps needs to be able to have to make it better, basically.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Can you guys keep track of cases, though, somebody orders something and turns out it's the wrong things?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think we would have that now, figuring my CDC on, right? Yeah, and we could do a lot of inferring, too, with RMA, we could match RMAs against it. We don't have structured data on that, but…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Can we touch up on the, like, we had an ML component to the project? I was just a bit curious about, it said that we have to, like, you know, for future also, we plan to use ML for further operations. How, like, which all aspects are you planning to use machine learning and, like, confidence scores and other things?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, I mean, content scores would be relevant to the part where, we predict these attributes for that product. So, equivalence, you get a certain product, in a certain activity, and you should be able to map these attributes, so in case the basic course you have.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We should be able to do some sort of step-by-step sampling, and then figure out what would be the appropriate attribute for this testing.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: context and emails.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But it's just… it's just mapping, and it's also, a little bit of, This was just gone.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: what could be the attribute for this specific feeling. That's also in terms of figuring it out in your attributes we can use.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And that's kind of the main thing. So, when we do make these predictions for these best academies, we do assign a conference for the year. And I think that's where confidence comes in.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Where you see… so the confidence score is a little bit more important. Exactly. So then the system learned that
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: this was low, and then beyond. This is the automatically corrected one. So that's the next step, right? So, you initially have given the rule, and then as you… as you keep getting more and more of similar errors.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: you can attach another part of the system which kind of rectifies itself, or you can still try and do that if it's goodnight. So it all depends on how the project goes, how it kind of turns out to me, and how it works, you know.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So are all the attributes spectra greens, or is there anything that's a photograph of a 3D rendering, or ammsterious will sometimes extend just beyond touch to a certain attribute?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We'll have images of, you know, docking, manuals, or spec sheets, or product pictures, yeah, but I don't think anything that would be an actual, like, fall under an attribute of skeleton.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, there wouldn't be, like, the aggraves in the case.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, Chris just mentioned that you have the category as one who has, like, a schema of attributes, right? So, if the attributes is the fixed part here, why are we applying the ML to the fixed part? Like, why do we need a confidence score to be assigned to this? Like, why not to the category, because
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's what is a variable thing, identifying with that process. I mean, it could be fluid, right? So, those patterns…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: you can try and turn the ketamine per product, which could be content. Next is, once you do figure that out and go into that, and we'll start things.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You don't know a specific… so, for example, if I say, A specific attitude, for example.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: take, like, the pressure of the percentage of the water or something like that. Like, for example, if it's 20 kilopascals per day.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: What we assign is actually, something like 20 seconds in a row instead. So, that would be for the attribute and the purpose code. So, it might not know the exact kind of,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: you need to put in there, value to put in there. It could be… it could just confuse that,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, I think as we, have, like, this internally, model-based kind of products.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: learn specific values for the team, you can close the jurisdiction of a green basket during the vertex of being virtual, then you would have to… even when we do validations for that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So that, you know, okay, these certain values are the exact sort of values you're looking at, because there might not be enough data to actually implement… But then, you, the values that we're talking about, do I, like… you mentioned in the spec talk, right? So, what's going on with the value? Again, so it's not going to tell you, like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: let's say it this way, different suppliers will provide different sets of athletes, like, like, Apple might ball spring size, spring size, and someone else might call it, like,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Or whatever, like, display size, or whatever. And sometimes it's not that cut and dry, either. Sometimes it's not just string size, display size. Sometimes it's, like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the gas flow rate versus the water flow rate versus, like, there is some interpretation to be done between suppliers to be able to match them up to a similar standard. Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Do your suppliers ever stop-check their data? I'm just curious if there was a feedback loop there now.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: On the outside, they do sometimes, that, on our side, we haven't experienced that so much, sorry.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Alright, I think it would break his…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, the manual process right now, we thrive to get the supplier to tell us our algorithm style.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So we give them a spreadsheet that describes the attributes that we want for these products. There's a lot of manual effort for them to actually build it out, and a lot of them just don't.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, they have the opportunity to try to make it right, but it's too much effort for either that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Thereabouts.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: maybe a good question, but was it ever the other way around? Did they come up and tell you that, okay, this is how we want the product to be, you know, categorized, or these are the attributes that, and then…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: what I mean to ask is, let's say the iPad. In your system, you just have 4, but then, since they know the internet working, maybe, like I'm just saying, are they like, okay, I need a first one. So, was there a requirement?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, so first off, we can totally take a fifth one right now, if they want to add in a particular attribute that isn't in that required set, that's fine. Is that even possible? Like, are they allowed to come up with a requirement that starts? They are.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Really able to define the data set for our catalog, because
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So they… they have their own data, right? They have their own catalog somewhere, and some days they… some of them can give us a lot of that data, and some of them can't, but,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Our job is to modernize data between different manufacturers, so we… we have to have the liberty to be able to change the modifier that begins with, for the sake of ease of use for the actual application.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, but also, some of the vendors could want, more so in the case of, like, ELPS.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: They could want their products to get more visibility to customers. They would want their products to show up in more searches based on more attributes, and especially when they're working out, like, the deal of
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the price they're going to be giving Alps for Alps to buy it from them. There's, like, all these negotiations, and a lot of times they will actually look at their catalog at Alps and see, like, hey, this is the way we're… you're showing our products, we'd like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Something like this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You know, next part.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Your experience with the previous two-year project that you guys have sponsored?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Any, like, just about the previous experience, any do's and don'ts that you have for us?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Individual mind.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: do, reach out to us on Teams, like, as much as possible, like, we do not mind getting, like, a lot of communication, a lot of messages, a lot of posts, like, we prefer that rather than, yeah, like, saving it all for the next week's meeting. Like, if something comes up like that, just reach out. It's, you know, we're all very,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we have very fast communication open, so I'd say that's a big one.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We were like, very briefly in the presentation, mentioned it, but we… we were like, this idea of after our January deal and debate.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, like, just because we're saying something needs to be submarried doesn't mean… like, you're already doing something that's great, or something that's bad. Yes.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we'll be glad to think of it differently, or explain why we shouldn't think of it differently, but, like, I'd rather have that discussion than things. We will never take offense to you thinking about it differently than we do.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: is probably the order as a document. They're no stupid virtual. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I would say, like, asking the same question again and again is still fine. It kind of helps to clear the gap and creates a lot of communication opportunities.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Also, I'd say too,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: follow up with us, like, if you…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: if we commit to something in a meeting, and you haven't heard much from us, like, quote-unquote, bother us, like, reach out and be like, hey, you know, like, I haven't heard back with this, like, again, we want that, as opposed to then we get to the next week's meeting, and it's like, oh, did you get a chance to do that when you forgot about it all week or something?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Any particular don'ts that you guys think?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You should be mindful of.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: kind of covered it in between. Probably, just don't go AWOL provider and then just pop up two weeks later, whatever. I mean, we completely agree with that, too, but it'd just be way more easier for us to keep practicing that help you guys are doing.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I'd say that's the main one. Other than that, we've had a pretty successful project right there. It's just that, I mean.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: to be fair, like, seeing the auditor doesn't be nice to look into that, and you do have, like, your studies and academics, that's what you guys, and it might be difficult to say that, but I would say if it's, like, a random 2AM, you think of something, and you send it, you have to say something, just send that to us. We'll take you to look at it for our own time, but we're still taking time.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It won't be brought in as NFL, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, you certainly not make this semester, they only have 4 hours a week to work on this. They have a few other things that are done, so each one of those kind of thing. Summertime is probably one more time at the end of the full day, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: How many tunes you would have done? Two or three, I don't remember how many. We had three. Three tunes? Okay, this is our fourth.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's good, yeah, it's good to be an experiment. I mean, when you get a new client who's never had any experience with this team, they think, the team is fully working for us 24-7.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: To your point, we're getting… we're getting better and better every year with how we're interfacing.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Well, a lot of it's about managing expectations, yes. I'm most of it.
Dennis Grinberg: And I'm gonna put words in the team's mouth, which is, you know, this is a lot of good experience and do's and don'ts.
Dennis Grinberg: from the team's… I'll actually ask the team, from the team's perspective, is there anything that you want from
Dennis Grinberg: from eParts, and how you work with them.
Dennis Grinberg: Have you thought about that?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We need to be good enough for them does.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think from my point of view, it was just the communication part, like, we are bound to have a lot of questions, because it's going to be a kind of a…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: struggling from scratch point of view, so we'll have questions, and if, like, you guys can respond, like, that'll be… I think that's the main thing I had in mind.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And that you already cleared up, so that's really good.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: This is our third, product data related.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: see a new project. So, sometimes, like, for me, sometimes it'll be hard to remember what I've shared with you versus, like, the other teams, so always ask clarifying questions.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Well, also, I guess, I guess one thing, too, just to do in previous experience,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we've had before, especially, like, with the initial PIMs, we had months of actually just kind of circling back to the initial kind of staying question. There's a lot of confusion, they weren't getting it, it's a very complex
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: distribution model. We won't really get into the distribution between our tenants, but my main point is, like,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: If there's, like, something you're still unclear on overall, like, we can keep revisiting it. We found that if we get a really, really concrete understanding of that, even if it takes a couple weeks of touching on it every week, it's gonna definitely be better anyway. Yeah, it's important to have domain knowledge from the team's perspective.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Go on to the next part. So, now we have the product usage.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think we've already touched up a bit on this, but…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Does the ingest pipeline… I don't think there's going to be a different, like, client interface, or how are we trying to, like, do we give clients something that they can, share the data with, or just, the PDF they already submit, and we just process it on our side?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For regulation pipeline.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, from the southern, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, we don't want to set, like, harder requirements on this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We… right now, on these files, we're getting, like, by emailing with the vendor. Sometimes it'll be big enough that I think Brian, who runs weekly or something that he sets up with them on his own. We intend… the best…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the best long-term reason on this is to make it as automated as possible, just, like, every time. One of them means to be that might be EDI, one of the means is going to be, like, FMP, but it could… I don't want to limit, but it could be, like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: setting up a way for them to see this and index it directly into our system. Like, I don't want to say there's absolutely no vendor interface here. They could be one of the best users to clean up some of that, human-in-loop type mistakes that the system is making.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So it just depends, on kind of our, our mutual, exploration of the problem.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I have a fundamental question here. So, since we have, like, so many vendors who are giving us data, I don't… obviously, like, they have some business requirements with the company, right? So, why don't we have a centralized portal, like, where they just… we just mentioned, some people get it in PDF form, and then some send it over email or DFP? So, why… why not a single format like this? So, where people
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We'll just feed in there.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: our data, and then we take it forward from you guys. That's the ultimate goal with him. We, originally had that with Tim from the very beginning, is
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: In addition to the client… in addition to the catalog teams, vendors themselves could come in here and maybe do the work themselves.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We'll… We'll be working on some of that this year, too. So there's… there's, like, historical reasons as to why we haven't done that in the past. The catalog maintenance team, historically has been very,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Like, they want to fully own the data that gets in the system, they don't want anyone else's fingerprints on it besides their own.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Even the vendors. So it was very intentionally manual for a long time. Now, we've drastically outgrown their desire to be intentionally manual. So yes, we are trying to answer questions like that, but it's not great for me.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Basically, one of the interesting experiments or research would be to take some data that… data sets you've had before, and sample data sets, we compare them to what's in FENS now, or whatever, just to see how they kind of map out.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And see where the gaps are in the crypto can deal with that. And also give them an idea of the data itself, right?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We're not answering the questions.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, about the product vision, I think we've also touched up on that, you know, pretty clear idea about it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, we can… maybe we can talk about the team responsibility and deliverables a bit.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, as,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: as a deliverable, it's just going to be a system, right, where we have the, like, engine pipeline with the ML model to array the attributes. So, okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Is there anything else you want to add on these points? Not just that, we wanted also, like, an application part of that that actually inserts something like the stage and things, right? It would be an additional river cylinder model,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: India, too, and in India, it's… it's just too low with… it's not for companies, like, so usually when the resources, depending on process it, probably churn out some sort of,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Predictions, or just programmatic, a programmatic approach to just put these things into the right attributes.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, we want that, the actually… the model, but then also something that puts what the model determines inside these tables. We do have staging environment, so we just have to be a dump for the data name.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then probably the community will pop in, and then you get the final data, which is probably roughly allowed.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Feeling.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We already have, the quick… our schema right now, basically, like, for the, like, product table.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But for every product options table, product attributes table, but for every table we have, we also have a staging product table, a staging product options table, a staging product attribution table. And these tables, that combination is how we have interfaced this. We're almost like a Git difference. They can see, like, this is the product before, and then these are the changes I'm making, and that's where they can approve or decide, no, that's not right, and they go back and change something again.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Ideally, we would just need the model, if you would like upload spec sheets, to just pop it into the statement table, and then from there, PIMS handles it, they can see the differences, they can choose to go manually edit more things, or whatnot, but
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, does that make sense?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I'm curious where the previous studio teams you worked with. Will they ever… did they ever do this an exercise of doing a statement award?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Requirements documents? We've gone through requirements.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's gonna be close.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Any other possible constraints or risks?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That would, like, we should take a keep mind while developing.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Without data sensitivity or something on that side? I mean, data sensitivity, just prices.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I would say, just to be looking at any of the data, we should be able to provide anything with whatever samples are expected. And,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We need this test is really to just put it all down. Understanding the exact scope and making sure that, we have adjusted for the annual risk.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think that those puppies.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, next is, about AI usage.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I just want to ask, like, how do you guys use AI today in, like, everyday development, or…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Around the company. For development, especially for coding, we've been pretty… pretty all-in for since February, since Bobcoding… I mean, Bobcoding, like, I started getting people in the public eye, but we use it a lot. We use Persons pretty extensively for all coding.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Of course, all got me inviting me to expanding off.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think the use cases of multiple data for planting, backend news.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: still paying, handling costs and stuff. We kind of…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Have the requirements and all the steps that are… then we sort of start implementing framework, and then go beyond the beginning of the week.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I guess, I think it's testing heavy at the event, so the way we do it is, we generate through it, we make sure that we test it extensively.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then, based on change in the attested step, the invoice, and it'll be blue.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Also gonna be, just to my, like, the MDs are, like, you know, we started to develop a practice now with the, like, documents inside the code so that it's reading the feature, like, the context is better.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Maybe a couple other things we're important. I mean, we do a few things with, like, compass management for, like, in terms of
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For example, if you're working with desktop features, so you wouldn't need the context of the entire application.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, we've had internal features testing, or markdown plans. Agent needed finding that. So, based off of that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Or at least keep maintaining the manual network.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And we're not, we use Cursor, and we all kind of… we evaluated Copilot early on. We all decided we liked Cursor, but we're not restricted to that. Like, if you all decide you want to use TalkBuild or something, or buy other tools like Cursor for what we already have our subscription.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I wanted to ask if we… for the, like, when we are using AI in our project, like, any part you would expect us to use it, like genetic code and, like, other things, but any other, like, your expectation of where we should be using AI?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, in addition to that point, we will do… I mean, I think that's the best use case we can go, which is why that's always coming out for me.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yes. So, from the record, I guess, let me know.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: making sure… I mean, even, like, decisions of, understanding what Facebook could be directed opportunities. You can use that to shut down. I would say it's just website recommendation would be other newspost.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Just a second.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And, for us using those elements, would be… should we use ours, or will we be provided one from EPA versus the subscription that you sell?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, so within Cursor, you can… you can choose for this prompt, I want to use Gemini, or you can switch it, I want to use the symbols, like Sonic, 4.5, or anything. Has anyone of you used Cursing at all? But, we do… I think we should be able to follow.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Also, you guys do not want us to use… like, I've been using anything I would be looking, and it seems to be doing a really good job, so do you not want us to use any other algorithms? You could, as long as, it's…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think, I think as long as the data is not based, right? Yeah. Well, we, other than that, it's another… Which is the privacy of the data? Yeah. Okay, we lose approval for that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: supporting Netherlands.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Would that be, from our side, or would that be, from, like, some start on the campaign?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think it would be, like.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We're in a close conclusion on our perspective time ago.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, I think a lot of the work you guys are gonna do is not of…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: were inside of it being hard to put 16 or anything like that. There was no bad, right?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And therefore, for all that stuff, like, as long as you're not instability incorrectly, things free throws, anything like that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I don't mind if you use it that you're having Andy share the stuff with him, right? It doesn't matter that it's not even ours yet. Again, as long as you're not, like, uploading vendor files to that, like, I don't want to be… yeah, I don't…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: we're not… all the vendor data isn't super sensitive, but I also don't want to just, like, wonky-nilly with it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But, yeah, you're welcome to move your own stuff.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Like, if they decide the plot is, like, good, like, I guess we paid for it. Is that what you kind of asked? Oh, that was what I was going towards, just from my experience when I worked at school.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I don't know what their education pricing is or anything like that. I think a bike ride that provides 5 code is, like, the minimum 300 bucks.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For a month, per person. There's really not a minimum 200 bucks a month to a person.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So that's… that's part of where my mind is at, but again, if it's a deep first, then we have a good rationale for why I should tell you that, or pitch it. No, I… And I am too, I'm just saying, if there's something that you're saying, that this is actually going to make it 30 times more productive, and there's no way of a product where it's like, here's a to-do list for our city.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Let's have the discussion.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, to be fair, almost all of these schools kind of have the same. They're all Asian-based, or kind of…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: application time. They all index files similarly, they all have restrict similar model access to them, similar instability. I think it's just a fundamental… exactly, it's just the underlying problems, like, probably kind of designed
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: EGU, right?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But it's super expensive, so, like, I mean…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And I would ask, but he spent our money, and yeah, it was your money. Make wise decisions. We're a small company, we're not legitimate enterprise, so it doesn't make a difference to us.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: But it also does make the difference to us that we passed, and getting the credit out faster, like, whatever. So, the… so the money side works on both.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: for us to spend money on this, but it'd be smart. That's all.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I think next, do you have any questions you guys might have, or anyone from the team?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's having out-of-pank questions?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah. So, I have one,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: How do the handouts happen? Like, do we have proper understanding, right? It depends on the story. So, so there were, like, three parts of the cluster. In one universe, the main, the data pipeline setting, which is scoping, and the visibility.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For that, we have, like, the proper knowledge times and daycare after this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We tried to set things up, and then I just tried to run their own books as well.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: and see if it was working, and if there were any change required. That was a… I mean, it was a super lightweight sessions with you all spent, and that's it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: For other things, the document and stuff, we had this kind of, like, documentation handout, where we had to fill it out on what our covers and what we had it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, it depends on the use case, and what exactly you use. It stands for probably SP Lumines, and, whereas a lot of code stuff.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: How does your current,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the code checking process look like? And starting from, like, the SFS talk, raising theirs, who are the stakeholders, then we should must get approved from? How does that look like? The bucket is what we use, and again, I think whatever emails they look, they probably need to restart the nose at the beginning of
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So you weren't really, the approvals and things like that. It should be internal. I would say you guys should probably let in as well, and that's up to you guys. Yeah, the only… the only time I could see modifications to, like, something we already have in this thing is, what we talked about earlier is, like, when it comes time to actually put the products in and…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We can talk down the road about how we want to do that, or maybe we just make some APIs that we've been playing a password or something down the road.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Or you could spin off of… spin off a committee to put down the subway station, so that you guys can install. And, we do also, though, we do use, sonar. We use… we use sonar for limping, too.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Do you guys use third-party for, like, security purposes? Like, something like a backdrop or something?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: To check vulnerabilities in the system? Security would be these, I think someone does it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So, that is pretty, extensive, very, extensive in terms of, what it covers. But yeah, it covers anything, so security to almost minor checks, too.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I have a trivial question. What were the names of the previous MSD to follow the team names? First one was Pensate means… and then there was,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Option logic will be, unknown event.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: That's alright. Last year, like, did we even have anything? There was, I think it was…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: They never used the name, they just used Epard's team.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, you guys should have a new one. That's a rule. Be more fun than what happens. I think it's always good to have a team name that is free to court. Yeah, no, it was fun, especially the very decor. And the logo is for the logo.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Interesting.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: There's a decent chance we'll be switching from Bitfucket to GitHub in, like, March. So, we'll see.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We don't have any political competition.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And you would be our first team using Winninger. We've been in Jira and Bodith has to lose a little more than Fire himself.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Obviously, it would need for us doing the onboarding tools. So what were your… what was your rationale going from Jira to…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I mean, one of the biggest benefits is that I think just… it's fast. Like, when you open an issue is no sentence instead of multiple seconds.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Also, the flexibility. You can very easily, like, earn something from initially to do a task, or, like, it's much more flexible, where Jira was a lot more, like, locked in with DB or the portal.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, it's also bringing the flexibility and the velocity. It accommodates everything, like, 49 stone building the velocity if it accommodates it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And probably just a spring cube. It has… it has support for that one. Probably these are really nice, but…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So… It's also a milestone-driven methodology in general, fully move, rather than having,
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: A task for the Msport and class itself.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's best for me.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And the UI is not better. Similar to the commercial product?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So we know we can show up, and those… Oh, yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: and… Oh, okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: So we're gonna have a, standing, fund meeting on Thursdays at this time every week to help the idea of the funds? I mean, and if there's… if it says tough, just shoot us some other times, yeah, we do have a couple reoccurrings on our side that we'll have to… that are kind of like, note, but other than that, if need be, we can get some other time or something. I mean, based on your schedules, too, I think that's the bigger factor, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yes, aren't… aren't days are pretty much pre-today and… today, for sure.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And based on your attributes, we can see what else also they can actually ask as well.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And obviously, change the message instead of being back in the year.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And I'll let you know that I like to attend with client meetings. I know Dennis won't be able to do that, but I always find it informative to understand what is the dialogue back and forth from the client getting started. I'll be informing the law. Okay.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Right there.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And last we have an action item review.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Any action items? So, for you guys, you, you segregate provide us the access using our annual email IDs, and to our mailroom as well. And then, for any doubts, just restating, the point of contact would be Harsha, Jake, and David.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And then, we'll also get access to their teams and the relevant workspaces, like documentation and stuff.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: a bulk of subscription, for the entire team.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And, I mean, not immediately, but then, I guess you would also share details on the current, data accuracy, like, with respect to
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: the existing quality metrics, like, if there's any defined, so that once we develop our system, we can just baseline and compare, how is… how's the whole thing improved or something like this.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: And on ours, yeah, we'll also, like, set up one recurring call with all of you guys who just check our calendars and then come up with a slot, and then we'll also have to, like, come up with one day where we visit the office and get to meet the parts calendar to understand how the current… how they're working on their business.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Where's the coming over?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I would also send directly inside the portal. Yes, for sure. That'd be great, that's it.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's both a pleasure to have you on board here. I know the team is excited, looking forward to working on this project, and I think in the end, you know.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You'll get an interesting project, and something that hopefully meets your requirements and meets your expectation-based success. So, we'll see how this works out.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We're also really looking forward to, the perp… kind of what the purpose of the project is more fancy. We're curious what… what not only this team, but all the teams buying with AI, we're also looking forward to that.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It's not a silver bullet, but it's something that's helpful, I hope.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Well, very good! This is exciting, yes.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I just have a slide deck as well. Yeah, sure. I'll turn them in. And be safe over the weekend.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: You too?
Dennis Grinberg: Yeah.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Go snowboarding on Monday if the weather slowed that much down, so you guys should be a first big storm. Yeah, you must have the December storm. Yes.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Were you in the store? No, no, I just left before the storm. But he was in Canada, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Well, years ago, when they had the super big snow cherry, CMUs are the kind of… they want you to come to school, but the city of Pittsburgh did come to close school. They closed the school. We'll see what happens on Monday.
Dennis Grinberg: Yeah, it'll be… it'll be interesting. I think there's some places, like, that aren't used to snow at all. Pittsburgh has gotten a little better about it, but, like, you know, DC, if they get a, you know, half an inch of snow, the city closes down, and they're supposed to get
Dennis Grinberg: Many inches, so it's gonna be… Gonna be interesting.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I was sleeping and staying on the front step yesterday, and there was nothing happening.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: The weather overnight, the sleet one where it was, is very slick, very slickering. Yeah, nasty.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Very good. Good to see y'all. Thank you so much.
Dennis Grinberg: Hi, everyone.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Yep.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Let me wait a second thing I want.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Are you still there, Dennis?
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Dennis, let the content. Alright.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, thank you. Thank you.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: Make movies.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: I would certainly say that after a client meeting, it's always good to have a follow-on with the mentors there, just to say what their perspective is on the meeting, if there's anything else that popped up. So, it's always good for you guys to also kind of have a discussion post-meeting about anything you heard, or something you need to follow up on, so…
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: We can stop on Friday.
hrishikb@andrew.cmu.edu: It was always good to record everything.